that other dip like the skull that
stuff's like stronger than that
school yes hey guys we're talking about
nicotine ingestion soul has tobacco in
it yeah that's what gives you cancer
this doesn't give you kids nicotine just
just makes you an addict
nick seem to make you an addict but yeah
you'll you'll take down tobacco to it
you'll throw four pouches in the morning
yeah with a nice dark roast four pouches
in your mouth that's good and then you
do another four
no only four right when i wake up what
did you just put in there three you look
like marlon brandon the godfather right
thanks man that's impressive how's your
braces doing
my braces are good
there was a lot of spitting in miami but
i had a blast were you warm on stage not
where i'm on stage here's the problem
why don't you just you guys
i got two and a half more months ago you
fox let me explain something two and a
half here's the problem about within
this line which i did or you told us
they told you if you restart yeah yeah
yeah if you they go we got to move all
the teeth so you can't not wear it just
for an hour when you're doing a
50-minute set it's fine and it's more
than a fit it's more than 50 minutes but
if he does yeah if you hour hour between
i get it 55 years old best some of the
best sets of my life this weekend so
that's all i care about at least your
teeth are okay my teeth and the crowd
understood you well with the teeth they
did they did but when i go to do a meet
and greet i take them out oh you do yeah
cause i'm a little self-conscious
[Laughter]
just puts them on a table daddy worked
on a sunday in miami daddy worked on the
sun how was that on monday i flew back
on monday
and what i didn't know was that on a
monday at after spring break and ultra
y
i made it on my plane with one minute to
spare both ways of course because that's
how i do it yep bite brian stuff yeah i
had to drop my car off at the rental you
take a tram
i walked a mile it was a mile i don't
know how if you if you have a problem
you're not walking that far i walked a
mile and i got there with one minute to
spare
and the line just for clear and
pre-check was crazy she goes well that's
the line i go that's clear what it's all
the kiddos snakes all the kids come from
spring break everyone goes to miami
looks each other's butts her body
everybody drugs and butts looking butts
drugs
drugs miami drugs but the music it's
just and then i was on the beach drugs
butts
and guns well that bees look like 55
years old the problem is when you're
alone on a beach looking like this
you're a [ __ ] creep you're korean so
you can't be sorry
i'm taking a walk and i'm i'm casually
planting at the asses i'm gonna ask a
question well that's my everybody got an
ass in miami everybody i'm gonna ask a
question though i mean like
south american women
latin women are the latin women
i'm gonna be i'm gonna make an objective
statement women are beautiful it's kind
of they're so beautiful yeah
and what is going on with that waist
to hip to butt ratio well it's just what
we're attracted to
god put him on the earth for that reason
how does one get anything done
and what i tell you you told me on text
i said and keep dating white women brian
i mean
the whole thing is insanity
[Music]
but it's his vibe and then you know
no i love my girl yeah but still italian
i don't mind yeah [ __ ] dude that whole
thing is a whole situation yeah they're
all ferrari colombia they're ferrari
yeah colombians yeah the best
it's the stupidest thing and positive
attitudes when you think about it very
nice 100 percent
miami is my favorite city and the dudes
there they don't really have to work out
they just kind of hang out and they just
got a good smile if they have money then
they have their dress nice greasy the
other gold chain like yeah gucci shirt
on button down to their phone oh good
and then my girl's at a 12. yeah you see
12s there you know there's there is
beyond ten whose joke is that is that
jeff dye's joke whose joke is that i
think that's what we just love and you
realize there's there's a scale from ten
to twenty yeah somebody said it was a
long time
yeah yeah and it's a hundred percent oh
my gosh yeah it was
like you get that vip that hollywood vip
line you get up there like oh there's it
goes above 10. yeah there's there's more
than 10. or just some or just some girl
in miami with some dude where you're
like
[ __ ] is going on here and the guy
probably just calls a hotel or some [ __ ]
something dope or they're just dudes and
they're young and they're just
some people don't even know what kind of
weaponry they're dealing with it's just
like no dudes have to be able to they
have to have something they have
something going on they have to have
something going on they can't just be a
rape you can't just be a regular dude in
miami no sir what are you going to do
why are you there
there's there's devils dancing money
yeah money's crazy though oh yeah yeah
well everyone during the pandemic all
the new yorkers you know all the la
people moved to austin or nashville all
the new york new yorkers came down to
140
so many people now big boy money's down
there yep
and then yeah we've always had big boy
money oh miami i mean remember miami
switched down to miami he's built off to
okay yeah that's all all the buildings
you see like oh hotel once cocaine hit
florida with pablo escobar and then they
had the the lady who ran all the cocaine
dude the buildings they were the whole
cities of cocaine and it's fantastic did
you get on a jet ski subscribe to it
what's that you know jet ski i'll answer
that no
no
thank you so much
oh
no hey we wrote jet skis i know we
weren't getting him by himself
was he a [ __ ] serial killer
[ __ ] hilarious
stupid
sunscreen
three times got invited three times to
go out on the boat different people come
out on the boat
and i didn't do that either you're not
going to catch me you're not going to
cast me out of there that's not for me
i'm not i'm probably not going to do
that what i'm going to do is have a nice
coffee maybe some food and i'm going to
write or i'm going to sit i'm going to
wander i love that i spent a lot of time
alone i got no problem with that did you
stay at a hotel i stayed at airbnb oh
airbnb yeah now i was in north miami
beach
airbnbs are tough in miami a little
tough unless you want to drop like 10
g's a little tough unless you're [ __ ]
you know damn blitzarian vibes correct
that's tough dude anywhere near miami
correct itself we did hotel last time
we did yeah
uh
oh that's right yeah because that let's
work there yeah
amigo let me go yeah yeah i should have
told you that you could hook you up with
a hotel really just remember god damn it
the continental it's a great it's right
on south beach that's nice it's really
nice sorry he just reminded me you know
what blame him he could have given me a
good deal yeah yeah you could have wrote
down a hotel during that time for under
never because lex throws the titan
fights out of there and he like runs the
whole play seems like hey and so food
everything where um
i just remembered oh yeah we yeah we
were bro remember the last show last
night we came back to our room and they
just had food for us food for days
but jimmy burke i'm talking about he
goes dude we had a great time in miami
this weekend for jerry 61st we were all
down there
i was in miami dude i was in miami it
was like what oh my god
yes i would have loved to offer they're
older so they're probably on social
media no they're not and i i think
that's your demo caught up with those
[ __ ] people they've been nice oh god
damn i was like what what you were here
that's good
what i could have
well that's a bummer that hurt me
a great weekend though overall
yeah now did you believe in look i've
said i said that you can't remind me
dude no that's too much for you
too much yeah
it's too much that's a lot more of a i
feel like you're more of a boca guy at
this point
i'm a miami guy i i know you're miami
for
i might be a miami guy for life the
problem is i don't know if it's good for
me
good for your skin i guess all right my
body feels
good yeah i love the moisture the skin
although you look kind of strange
did you oh yeah yeah yeah it's just
because like lukewarm might be hard
whenever that opens
what the [ __ ] yes you pissed you just
like atlantic huh yeah piss hard in that
water if it's real warm i just want to
pee sure
now you're a big handsome brown kid yeah
you get some people you
hungry eyes at you in in miami i feel
like i guess i'm like a six in miami
yeah i mean they're beautiful people
though yeah they're so good like
everyone's flat and everyone's dressed
to the nines like you're the mall guys
have suits on it and jacked
the worst thing about miami the customer
service
nobody's in a hurry you go to starbucks
you're there for 30 minutes it's a
[ __ ] drink [ __ ] 100 it's just this
that latin vibe where it's like there's
no rush they're taking that kind of just
go with the flow
the customer service is awful we'll take
our time and we're coming from l.a or
from new york like hey let's go here man
like whoa whoa whoa
very slow pace that drives me nuts did i
tell you that
the funniest story my friend who's a phd
and i know these for my feet
daddy daddy's got to have a wide toe box
it's a whole situation my on clouds but
these are not good you still haven't um
no but these are very did you get an
insole though
no yes i have two i have two different
shoes that have insoles so i've been
wearing take them out and put them in
those you should wear those all the time
i agree although these are best best
thing on my feet yeah but the in it's
not it's a it's about
yeah how come you never listened to him
on this no i do i had it the worst i saw
all the experts yeah i do i swear i do i
went right to the place you went to now
when you you flew back on monday so then
sunday night you're playing on stage did
you happen to watch the oscars
thank you for the tee up you know i
didn't watch the segways um i didn't you
know what i hate them i always watch
them yeah there's some about it i uh did
you watch the slap live i watched
everything
well you couldn't because in
north america they have i think they
call it a lag a lap so they edit it for
10 seconds like what the [ __ ] going on
then we came back you just tell the vibe
was different
then mark harley shout to mark carly
he
literally two minutes later texted a
group we have a group called beat your
ass tour he [ __ ] he texts the group he's
like holy [ __ ] you see will smith slap
chris rock i'm like what
and so i look i'm like oh that's fake
that's not real
i thought it was fake yeah and he sent
the the full version with the whole
thing you're like oh that was real keep
holy [ __ ] out you're [ __ ] see when he
caught when when see i i just saw the
slap and like and then then the video
marched out originally they're just
walking back i'm like oh that's a bit
that's that's strange that's weird yeah
because they didn't he didn't give the
[ __ ] when you see how emotional he is
when you keep my wife saying about your
[ __ ] i'm like oh they wouldn't write
that in especially him cussing because
they can't hear them like oh he's he's
for real and then if you saw the
extended version chris rock
goes over like he leans out he's are we
good man what's going on like literally
like what's going on with you dude it
was like he jailed i didn't know that he
was is a joke you mean after after and
then no no like before he goes back up
and does which we saw in north america
on the live broadcast
after he gets slapped you know he's like
oh my god it's crazy but then he does
the documentary bit he's like let's
throw it to whatever you know he's all
flustered he goes down he goes are we
good man the [ __ ] going on with you
what are you doing
and then you see samuel jackson denzel
washington and bradley cooper like
coming over to will smith and like you
know to make sure he's okay
it was just well i think
denzel washington said the greatest
thing the devil comes to you at your
highest moment oh that's cool that was
strong yeah that's a hundred percent
strong in some cases yeah but
what did chris rock say at this point
well you don't
yeah i mean i'm sorry what did what did
will smith say to chris ross nothing oh
after after didn't say anything no i
mean i would have been it was so
shocking you'd be like
you know what i mean like
here's a question for everybody in this
room
name
one other public place
whatever it is tv movies where wherever
you're at award show any award show
sporting event comedy
any other public race
political whether you know it's a debate
whatever name any other public place no
matter who you are where a man can get
up slap another man and sit back down
and people clap listen listen where
there's no repercussions
he got a standing up so hollywood is the
most is the most two-faced
[ __ ] in the world it's the most
spineless horseshit it i've never
hollywood first of all what you saw that
when will smith did that i understand
you had a moment i have a whole take on
this okay but when you see that it's
like all i think is pure narcissism like
it's just the narcissism all across
about jada pinkett and they're all just
it was just it was such a [ __ ] now i
like
the hell i love will smith but how but
how weird is it to eat you to just see a
word show in general but how weird is it
like there's literally a war going on
kids died women don't you think and
you think and then and then this is
going on it's just so strange
yeah exactly like like how big are your
egos in hollywood there you go where you
think people give a [ __ ]
an officer doesn't mean too much these
days at all let me ask you a question
let me put this out for you i i'll tell
you why i think it happened and you tell
me okay here's what i think and i want
to get your team
i think
i don't know i admire anybody in
hollywood who can make a relationship
like jada pinkett and will smith have
made okay get that relationship together
say whatever you want an open
relationship yeah but yeah yeah yeah
being open my my feeling is this it
feels like
go for it will smith's at the top of
this game crushing it didn't a great
actor and beloved by america uh-huh okay
i think jada pinkett
can't stand the fact that her husband is
crushing it
i think okay hold on hold
bad take hold on those are stinky hold
on
it's a hot trash but i'm finished with
that i think well you might not know
actually that's the way i do but i'm
done with you i don't know
the relationship so hold on you're way
off so i also think go for it that
she's kind of humiliated him from what
i've said there you go
on this red table red table [ __ ] yeah
now you're understanding that he's
taking a lot of [ __ ] we don't know about
him
he's taking no hold on all
the [ __ ] it ruined his reputation thank
you because they're an open relationship
and they really don't talk about that
and she brings it up oh yes and he goes
excuse me embarrassment she bring it up
she brings it up because she wants to
take his power away from him that's what
i'm saying
i don't think it's him being a celebrity
because no no no no no i'm sorry and
he's crushing it she i think she's so
her way of taking his power away is by
humiliating him and but also remember
she's also monetizing that
reviews on that are insane also wrote a
book all the she's monetizing all this
stuff yeah so what i'm saying is this is
lady macbeth this is this is a woman
who's an actress who has to somehow she
can't let him shine she's got to take
his [ __ ] away by humiliating him on her
[ __ ] show and it's ruined his
reputation he's been so many memes and
people talk [ __ ] about him exactly but
then also what's worried about one more
let me just finish okay so now
the the motherf so so he uh chris rock
makes a poor joke about her alopecia
okay alopecia you
alopecia so you can see her apparently i
didn't see this from what i heard she
rolled her eyes yeah he was laughing he
was like he laughed but he got one look
at this oh i better go like this you're
gonna let you're gonna take that correct
now now as a man he's got to go do her
fighting so she's sitting back like this
and i guarantee all the [ __ ] he's taken
for this she loves that's my take on it
i and and and i like i think she loves
he stood up for it and she thinks it's a
cool way to start cover i think there's
a side of me that likes that old school
that i like there's a side of me do i
struggle with the people i struggle with
it i like the old school [ __ ] i like
that if you're gonna talk [ __ ] there
should be consequences in this day and
age and yes especially in hollywood yeah
so many people talk about it
and there's no repercussions there's a
better way to deal with it but i also
think this was the straw on the camel's
back i think will smith has been the
[ __ ] butt of the joke yes for years
and years and years because of his wife
and this red table talk show and they
keep making fun of them and what they
don't realize is and will said this like
yeah they're an open relationship and
she was very adamant about you know
augustus guy that rapper who she got
sober and then started [ __ ] them
which is so strange yeah yeah and but
will we know of a couple women that he's
hooked up with
but will's hooked up with tons of women
but he's not out there making her look
bad about it because he respects her she
doesn't has he's hooked up with her yes
okay they're an open relationship she
she doesn't respect him like he respects
her right so i think this was the strong
camel's back where he was like all right
dude [ __ ] this yeah and i also think
it's a bit of a [ __ ] move for will
smith the bigger man because he goes oh
but chris i can expect chris i was gonna
ask you this question because that was
the rock no no [ __ ] the rock
clearly not the rock because rock wasn't
there i'm not sure on the shop show i
said if that was jason momoa doing those
jokes thank you would you have kept the
same energy i'll answer that absolutely
that's what i'm asking jason mamo's a
much better because he was there much
better and he was presenting jason is up
there you're not doing it
yeah exactly but then remember
and this is internet chatter so who
knows if this is legit but schultzy
brought this up to me when we were
talking
chris rock in 2016 hosted the oscars and
lit jada pickett smith up right because
she was trying to boycott it yeah and he
was like that's like me boycotting
rihanna's panties
it's funny she's also boycotted so it's
hilarious
yeah it's fine but apparently will smith
and chris rock talked prior to this like
years before he's like dude you gotta
chill out on that [ __ ] i'm telling you
man so he's warned him several times and
then chris rock's joke was not in the
teleprompter it was off the cuff i agree
and it wasn't a great video yeah it
wasn't even
dude [ __ ] you yeah but that's also not
like it's not like she has [ __ ] you
know
dementia it's kind of a big deal though
when you're losing your hair it sucks
yes and no she she still looks sexy as
[ __ ] it could be people she's not as
[ __ ] people people are dealing with
way worse i think people are dealing
with way worse problems but also chris
rock came out and goes i had no idea she
had that uh-huh he was i have no [ __ ]
clue i was gonna say did you know i have
no did you know
[Applause]
gijn can't wait that's a that would be
as a comic
they're just just always it's like it's
a throw away
it wasn't written the teleprompter so he
was just doing his thing but apparently
according to twitter and who knows
what's wrong fake on twitter but will
smith warned him like dude you keep
going after my wife i'm telling you be
[ __ ] careful and then we got to the
ward chris was like [ __ ] it they're
front row he threw the joke and then
will's like i've warned you i've been so
disrespected i got to do something now
but again respect me too part of me you
can't do it i'd probably defend my girl
same way you can't put it there you
can't do it then you wouldn't do that i
think you should have stood up and went
i [ __ ] told you dude i told you keep
my waist wife's name out of your [ __ ]
mouth when this is over i'ma see you in
the back that's how you should have
handled it or wait till you're in the
back no do it then you can make a scene
so everyone knows you stuck up for your
girl publicly yeah you go i'm gonna see
you in the back [ __ ] i've told
you twice now now when i see in the back
it's on it's on site [ __ ] that's
fine there you go that works for me 100
but also what's crazy name any other
profession any even acting any other
profession where he can physically
assault a human being and suffer no
reproduction no no excuse me get a
standing ovation standing over yeah he
was great in that i remember just the
same crowd that also gave a standing
applause to that uh what's it roman uh
polanski
clearly clearly he [ __ ] a 13 year old
in the ass in a hot tub and he can't
come to back to america he [ __ ] a 13
year old and he can't come back to
america he has to stay live in france
and even when he's in france they give
him a [ __ ] oscar yeah and they gave
him a standing applause now also
and it is i have no issue with this it's
not against the law there's nothing
wrong with it how hard were people
laughing at leonardo dicaprio dating
younger women that was fun how hard were
they laughing at regina hall talking
about oh i'm going to do a cova test
because i'm single and she made a joke
about will smith and jp that's fine i i
truly believe this that will smith went
well
chris rock is smaller than me he's kind
of a [ __ ] now's the time to do it and
i've we have a history now it's time to
do it now i'm gonna stick up for my go
after all the [ __ ] i've been through i'm
gonna do it yep i think he had a moment
of madness
i mean i think i think
think he uh channeled his inner [ __ ]
venus williams dad yeah i was like i'm a
protector i still love this [ __ ]
i love will smith but it was a [ __ ] move
and i he's got to be embarrassed that
that's how i said he apologizes he
apologizes next day like [ __ ] but you
know what's weird though is he he has
pictures where he was taking pictures
with kids he's mimicking the slap he
went and danced getting jiggy with it
and he's pretending he's slapping people
so it's a little tacky
leaning into it but i also think you
know the hollywood like judd apatow you
know complete soy boy talented the
biggest sword but in the world if if if
we're at war with russia
trust me he would run to mexico that's
him yeah and he goes he tweets out uh i
can't believe will smith did this you
know he could have killed him
what yeah i know hey sir have you ever
been punched in the face before you
killed no are you out of your mind well
he really said that yeah he had to he
deleted the tweet because i'm sure be
like hey dude this is a complete boy
post you want to talk about violence
it's ukraine yeah yeah that's important
but it was like she was she was talking
about uh this one pundit like a a
journalist she's a
black woman i can't remember what she
was talking about she goes here i got
three words use your words and she goes
start talking about it because and
frankly i'm embarrassed
that i'm taking the time to talk about
this [ __ ] when we got ukraine we've got
so many issues and and
i can't believe i'm talking here's my
other thing
i truly really don't give a [ __ ] yeah i
don't care dude so this this this
billionaire slapped this other bill in
it
yeah
you they're fine and then adam sandler
dealt with it best he posts chris rock's
tour that i've put go to uh adam
sandler's instagram channel he posted
his tour dates
he blows tour dates and he's on his and
his new uh
look at chris
oh happy birthday chris delay it's his
birthday oh yeah go give him some
ego death
chris rock ego death world tour
can't wait for this i love you buddy
it's going to slap boss logic shout out
to boss logic that's so funny
i also think if i'm chris rock
you know obviously you're you're
you're kind of out of it when that
moment happens you oh you no one
predicts it what but but it's
embarrassing it's [ __ ]
what are you talking about like you know
he's done that and there's also a rumor
he had a broken arm he just came out it
doesn't matter you'd be like there's no
counter
no he leaned forward
people don't know what they're saying if
you watch him he goes like this he was
like he's going to say something to me
like yeah you know and they said i'm
like whoa what the [ __ ] but then i but
also i would
again it's all in hindsight i think
chris rock is the skill set that he has
it's been so dope if he doubled down and
there's so much material to light will
smith and j opinion smith up on yeah if
you would have doubted him like oh you
think that was bad yeah he was well if
you want to hit me i'm going to give you
a reason to hit me
did you see
what he posted no no go to san francisco
it's funny too he said finally some
black and black crime at the oscars
sam tribally put put on
he's so funny
it goes right where is it
no not this one no it just said no no
keep going down i'm sure it's that first
one sorry i just said i just said it's
it's a picture of jada pinkett maybe it
was a tweet he did it's there it is
right there right there our wife
keep my watch out your [ __ ] mouth
august our wife
yeah he ain't lying yeah that's not his
original post but yeah oh okay
that's the
side piece that was a side piece that
she was [ __ ] she would fly him to
hawaii on family trips like everyone's
having fun at the pool
i'm gonna no i'm going to go get dick
down by this young man now change the
rules change the rules tell me how this
would go in society say will smith took
a young girl i think he was 22 or 23.
don't help me out here no help me out
here help me out tell me all the skills
be this is hollywood this is why nobody
believes hollywood they're complete yeah
[ __ ] two-faced sociopaths
imagine if will smith narcissus imagine
if will smith took a young girl who's an
addict alcoholic at 2023.
her shelbert and started [ __ ] her
and then was out about it how how would
society treat him it'd go great for him
now everyone's like oh go go jada get it
girl excuse me
what's female empowerment dude
how weird is that it's just called
hypocrisy now no but also imagine jp
smith to disrespect you listen
openership that's okay what do you think
hippocrates
i respected open relationship if that
works for you more power to you imagine
being on a family trip in hawaii with
your kids
and your wife goes everyone's good on
drinks and lunch i'll be right back i
mean it too cause augustus is in the
other room
i mean i mean it's so wrong it's so hot
is it crazy yeah it is crazy it it yeah
i mean but i i think will doing this is
just you know uh it's a moment of their
relationship either the other thing is
like that's the thing that's top of the
world and you can be in hell but you can
be on top of the world and you and
everybody thinks your life's amazing and
your home life might be one
big
[ __ ] lie yeah right or you might just
be
miserable i think my mileage i don't
care if another man slaps another man i
really don't give a [ __ ] no my only
thing is it's a bigger man slapping a
smaller man yeah it's a form of bullying
you wouldn't have done jason momoa it
was the bright opportunity to do it to a
smaller man you know he's not going to
defend why you don't it's actually why
violence is that when they say violence
is wrong it's not the reason you don't
have violence reason you don't have that
is this watch it'd be like okay i'm
tough i'm really tough i train i'm 170
pounds i beat i'm a champion
but there's always a guy like you who is
just bigger 270 size matters yeah well
i'll say
whatever it is whatever
right now okay
okay all right take it easy
that's that's not the point of story i
know you said 270. okay dude let me make
you 270. no he got hurt by that 270 dog
why just i want to get facts right all
right you're 250 working really hard
yeah yeah all right dude i know i'm
sorry
give or take right yeah no i mean some
days i'm done the other day it's 2 47.
okay maybe and maybe you're lying
to chicago okay and then i had some deep
dish pizza and [ __ ] my pants all right
so you get you get a little yeah it
fluctuates from 47 to yeah 70.
uh but so all of a sudden you come in
and beat the [ __ ] out of somebody right
you know what happened and then what
happens is i go okay i can't do that i
gotta i got a knife next time and then
next time you got a gun and the next
time you bring your friends and it just
escalates so [ __ ] quickly and next
you know you have a [ __ ] war we know
that's what happens we know that it's
biggie right yeah you can't violence
will always escalate into a situation
where what what what you end up going to
do
that's why you have to keep boundaries
on that there's never been an exception
to that yeah it's just never been that's
why you have weight classes i think uh
what do you see the comic george wallace
tweet out he goes hey he's also probably
oh yeah
i'm six four two eighty he was trying
that [ __ ] with me on stage tonight and
for like somebody's dating
and then eric griffin tweeted goes damn
i need to hit up brendan's shop get some
training if we're gonna start slapping
people on stage everybody's been calling
me all the people like my family and
friends and they're like dude is this
something you're worried about now i
mean this has to be something you're i'm
like i i i yeah i would like that very
much i hope somebody gets out yeah i
encourage you yeah please do it because
i'll go viral and really hit me up yeah
yeah especially you if some guy comes up
and just slides i came up to you they're
not stupid enough they're gonna come up
with a gun which is a different story
but it'd be good though if you just took
the slap and and you were just like
threw this up and you're going like that
you got to get your body into it like
dude you get started
dodge knock him out no but um
i think to comics who are like oh really
this is acceptable on stage like well
that wasn't a comedy stage also
don't get around chris rockman the
greatest comedians ever do it he's also
super hollywood he's an actor that's an
actor slash comic
given an award the reason he's not there
because he's a comedy he's there because
he's in hollywood so it's a big
hollywood figure talking [ __ ] to another
hollywood figure this isn't some comic
on stage like it was like like take a
straight comic like who's not in
hollywood take a take uh billboards
hollywood marc maron
uh you know take a big comic he's not in
hollywood say chappelle you know he's
not really
hollywood board lines he's been in
movies but let's say a guy who's not so
hollywood rogan rogan's perfect he
doesn't [ __ ] with any hollywood [ __ ] but
furthest thing from
it it's not like rogan's on stage and a
random person comes up and slaps them
right this is so where comics are like
oh my god dude this is acceptable and
nothing happens like dude relax yeah he
was gonna go for hollywood this is
excuse me this is a very famous person
slapping another very famous person i
don't know what it was this is like
it was such an ambush too like the last
so so if i were to say
okay
i mean the last place
that you'll ever get slapped in the face
the last would be the oscars would be
when you're giving a speech at when
you're presenting a word at the oscars
it's the last place you're gonna get
never happened before and it's really
the last place you're gonna get slapped
by will smith the last thing you're
thinking is i might get slapped by will
smith yeah there's a better chance of a
meteor or a cobra fighting its way and
actually biting it literally there's a
better chance of amy we're telling a
good joke yeah there's a better chance
maybe she's been telling a good joke
yeah
she's
yeah don't even start yeah
but yeah that's right
that's right and and here's the other
thing you know comics want to jump down
people's throat
amy schumer chris rock is a mentor to
her he's helped her out in so many ways
a lot of comics were yeah how do you not
defend chris rock let's say and i give
this example on the shop show let's say
theo was presenting at the oscars and i
was also on there
and they had me going up right after him
if something happened to theo i would
get on that mic and light will smith and
his wife up man yep i would not be she
made a joke she was like oh i heard
something happen uh it's weird in here
excuse me yeah that's your boy man
defend him you have the chops to do it
amy schumer's a beast she's a beast man
she can roast she's b she came up like
that yep she's the chops you know
go up there and defend if someone did
that to you at whatever award you should
never do i would get up there like
hold up that's no i know i need to do my
thing real quick will jada
boom i got jokes for days for youtube
[ __ ] you guys give me too much
material yeah how do you not defend your
man because she's not that kind of
person she's too hollywood she does no
[ __ ]
but i mean is it too hollywood she'll do
whatever but they're killing this should
be like this that was popular she'd be
like let's kill this is hollywood in
general though just so you guys know how
nobody has a background i know nobody
they have to sell tickets no nothing's
real that's right if they went hey if
you talk [ __ ] about will smith right now
you'll sell more tickets in north
carolina that's right and they're going
to do that yes even though you grew up
with him from day one but just watch the
oscars first it was gender reassignment
surgery then it was global warming
there's a cause every time but they seem
to forget about it
it's [ __ ] unbelievable it is
interesting the situation is trash
you know what else is it's not that big
of a deal it's not like it's just
[ __ ] it's another billionaire
slapping a billionaire tuxedo they're
both fine but nobody watched a lot of
people didn't tune in no the ratings
were dog [ __ ] yeah dog [ __ ] it was
awkward it was like dj khaled started
being like this weird hype video it was
all dog really
dude i've watched every occasion
i love the hollywood [ __ ] i love it i
watch all of them it was dog [ __ ] and so
amy schumer got back got on stage after
that and didn't say anything no she went
oh she was it was funny for you know
what she did she goes oh what's up
everybody i feel did something happen
strange you know like she's oh she just
did that that's actually she's getting
heat which you know this this is our the
world we live in she's so crazy because
kristen dunst is married to that uh
phenomenal act i forget his name not
handsome but um
she go she goes i want to talk about um
seat fillers
she has what a seat filler's job does if
someone has to get up and go to the
bathroom on camera they don't want the
space open so she goes and sits down a
seat filler sits down their seat okay
she goes like here's a seat filler and
points to kristen dunst like she doesn't
know her and she's he's so good yeah
dude
he wasn't breaking bad he was dude he
was in black mass he's excuse me black
mask top three [ __ ]
amazing black married yeah episode i
think four yeah oh damn kristen dunst
what's up kids
[ __ ]
all right that's his girl he's such a
good actor i'm gonna talk about your
girl like that a unique looking dude a
unique looking dude
body like a lunch lady he's a great bad
guy yeah there's a movie called windfall
that's on netflix really good he's
phenomenal yeah i mean he was up for an
oscar for god's sakes and whatever the
black dog or what the [ __ ] this is a
good actor he's so good but amy schumer
again amy schubert's getting [ __ ]
because she was like uh
you know she was like like this girl's
you know obviously the
this is the joke she points kristen done
she goes like she's a seat filler so
someone had to go to the bathroom his
girl had to go to the bathroom so she
fills in and she's like what she's like
excuse me get out of her seat filler and
sits down and interviews her husband
because they're
engaged and people are upset about that
which is ridiculous yeah who gives a
[ __ ]
hollywood in nutshell yeah what a
[ __ ] yeah it's just kimray came out
and uh addressed that because she said i
actually know kristen dunst and she
knows about the joke she was fine with
it yeah i don't know why everyone else
is back i didn't find it offensive
look i mean jokes or jokes they should
be a little offensive how about that
yeah how about how about how about if
you're if everybody in the room likes
you you're not a comic ricky gervais is
so funny he tweeted out you know so many
people were asking me uh
if i would have hosted oscars what i
would have done
and he goes uh first of all i'll never
host them he was um you know i host the
golden globes because they give me full
range for creativity and write whatever
i want and i don't have to do like i
don't have to go over the jokes with
them they just they don't know what
they're going to get i go on stage as a
comic it's the best thing in the world i
can light everybody up they have no idea
what i'm doing and he goes with oscars
he's going to limit me i have to do
rehearsals and he's like you know i
don't want to do that because i'm going
to take away my jokes he says a comic it
doesn't make sense and so he said he
would have got on went it's good to see
everybody and he's talking about there's
so many different uh it's good that the
oscars is so diverse now something black
latinos whites this is great don't
people aren't allowed in here is poor
people
[Music]
poor people am i right
oh [ __ ]
the best
but [ __ ] poor people am i right well
somebody asked somebody asked one of
these like it was a professor who writes
all these books on race and stuff like a
white
person and
and they were talking about inequality
and stuff and somebody said when was the
last time you had somebody who works
with their hands at dinner at your house
have you do you have any friends who
smoke do you have any friends that are
plumbers landscapers people that
actually do construction was the last
time you had anyone like that and is
there anybody in your family like a blue
collar and yeah this person was like
[ __ ] you know i've been talking about
inequality i don't have one friend that
even was in the military yeah you
weren't even you don't even have friends
that were that served in the military or
law enforcement and that's what you
don't know and you have all these
opinions yeah you don't all literally
all your friends at your house that you
have that you go on vacation with that
you have that you're around when you
work yeah are all upperclassmen all
privileged they're all privileged
they're all upperclass people
never worked with their hands it's very
rare to see a real rich person handling
corporates what's great about what we do
as comics is that our my audience is
real
real people yeah yeah and we get to have
a connection with them face to face
right and you realize that you're not
smarter than there is there's just
difference there's just a different
experience if anything you have a
liability because you're around one
[ __ ] small circle of people stephen a
smith went hard in the pain on it he was
talking about right away and he was like
man he's like people give so much [ __ ]
about you know uh black people the
ruined stuff and he's like this is what
they're talking about
he can't take us anywhere
he's like will smith what the [ __ ] are
you doing this is the worst mistake of
your career man he was finally gonna get
to the party what do you say he tagged
the wrong wolf smith in his tweets oh he
did
it's a white guy with the name
the guy tweeted him back like oh yeah
he's like please don't do this that's
hilarious
i like him though smith
oh [ __ ]
that's hilarious
not that will smith at is his twitch
that's really funny man man when i first
went to him he had 175 or 125 000 he got
up 125. that's hilarious
um yeah man i don't know
yeah hollywood
it's just dumb yeah i just and i love
the the the oscar the academy goes uh we
do we do not promote violence congrats
everybody that won tonight and then now
they get so much backlash like you know
what we're going to review the tape and
see exactly what happens
i like i like uh i like the speech i
like will smith's speech
i want to be a vet i didn't watch it
i won't be a vessel of love not violence
oh i didn't see that part that was a
speech that was amazing he was like
tearing up right yeah like because i
want to be a vessel of love it's like
dude you just slapped a man on national
tv what are you talking about he's a
good actor man he was great in that
movie i love that movie he's [ __ ]
amazing in that movie
let's take a little break dude talk to
me about see i want a bike but i don't
want to get out there on my bike you
want to hit the road it's dangerous i
want to get more dangerous it's
dangerous i want i want to get a workout
in from your home
but i also want to listen to music and i
want to do other things besides bike i
want to do yoga i want to do boxing bro
i got you b i got you old man i got you
a wrinkly man i
your boy's been a member for six years
all right now pelton they bring the bike
to your crib it's so much fun the best
music can
the best mix you want to listen to they
get your heart rate up you're losing
weight you're losing can i always i want
to do some boxing they just added a
bunch of new stuff for the new year
boxing do i need gloves nope nope nope
nope nope it's fast it's furious you get
to work out with an instructor is that
it's so much fun and dude you're you're
burning college you only know it you're
having so much fun i hear they have a
new artist series music what are you
into b-pop rock hip-hop
we have over 100 artist series to choose
from all right can i get a variety in my
workout say i want to do a 30-minute
workout maybe a 20-minute strength
workout what if i want to do a quick
cardio at 15 minutes we got it total
body work dude we have all that with
pelton stay motivated while having fun
with the bike workouts yoga meditation
dance cardio boxing and so much more
visit onepeleton.com to learn more
that's onepelton.com o-n-e-p-e-l
you gotta get your greens in dude i'm
glad you said this i don't like eating
salad i'll be honest with you sometimes
i don't want to eat all the fruit dude
sometimes i want to take that much time
27 heads of broccoli no i don't so what
do i do fart but i want my i want my
vitamins i want my minerals i want my
whole source food ingredients i want my
multivitamin multi mineral i want my
probiotic dude everything you just list
listed off is ag-one what athletic
degree one athletic greens one contains
75 vitamins minerals whole food source
ingredients including a multivitamin all
the stuff you just mentioned it's
delicious i just put that packet in my
freaking eight ounces of water and your
boys hitting the ground running dude all
right we got you covered man join the
movement of athletes podcasters comics
moms dads first timers everybody doing
it man what if i wanted vitamin d what
if i want some vitamin d talk to me
about need more d in your life man get
five free travel packs for the first
purchase if you visit athleticgreens.com
fighter today again all you got to do go
to athleticgreens.com fighter to take
control of your health and give ag-one a
try and i hear they give you a free
one-year supply of vitamin d is that
true yep and five free travel packs
bring it
yeah anyway any [ __ ] ways yeah it's
all any [ __ ] ways there's so many
memes and all sorts of [ __ ] about it now
it's great give us something to talk
about i don't mind again the end of the
day i kind of like there's a part of me
with you it's like that's old school man
you talk about someone's wife you get
[ __ ] slapped there's repercussions
it's been awesome you can't do that yeah
but then at first i liked it and then i
just me too me too at first i was like
hell yeah yeah and then i was like
yeah that's not good i started taking an
account like you're doing like jason
mamo are you yeah i'm like you can't
have like a kind of [ __ ] now if he
had done that to jason momoa and stood
there i would have been like that guy's
a bad thing like say something yeah yeah
yeah you're like oh [ __ ] this is cool
yeah they said chris rock was making
jokes when we got in the back he's like
damn i just ate a punch from [ __ ]
muhammad ali because then i didn't go
down and then literally just talked he
met with the lapd i'm sorry the the lapd
and the
production staff of the oscars and then
just got his car and left went back to
his hotel that was it yep oh he left
right after that moment literally you
got checked out they didn't did they
have more to do after that no no okay
but usually i'm not pressing charges all
good and left
chris rocked up yeah why would yeah
dealt with it like a beast yeah all
right [ __ ] it
it's it's
well it's like what's your take on this
be so uh you know mazela doll sucker
punch colby come to a
dinner in miami
and now colby comes in he has a chipped
tooth he scratched his 90 000 rolex and
he's pressing charges now
i don't like these person charges
i i think that i think it's a man it's
kind of like i know but
there's no other way to get back at him
and he's really mad i'll tell you get
back i'll take it back down run it back
yeah run it back run it back but he
already did it in this yeah but now it's
like all right bro i'm gonna beat the
[ __ ] out of you again yeah i tell the
hey dana i'll tell you what i'll drop
the chargers because if i press these
charges he's going away for two years at
least do you think so oh yeah
aggravated manslaughter
assault you're [ __ ] super [ __ ] i'd
say hey dana the only way i'd drop these
charges if you make me the main event in
july against mazdawa once again let me
legally beat the chev and make millions
of dollars and give me a higher
pay-per-view points wow
that's what i would do yeah that would
be my business move not a bad idea hey
ufc i know you want mazzola fight again
and he's a big star cool i'll drop the
charges and you'll be able to have him
fight again but yes fight me next i mean
that [ __ ] is so out of control the fact
that he did that
it's you know you know what it is it's
such a [ __ ] move and i interrupt love
mosvidal but it's such a s soy boy move
to sucker punch somebody that's awful
because anybody can say you don't have
to be trained or a badass you know it's
not hard it's [ __ ] it's not hard to
succeed
but but here's my thing be if but just a
sucker i i've been cool with it if
you're gonna fight in public you guys
have that and much animosity you want to
fight in public yeah do your thing it's
old school west do your thing but go up
to the guy like hey [ __ ] you
talk [ __ ] about my kids right don't
sucker punch him right did you see the
video of him bragging about the sucker
punch on ariel
years before he goes i'm known for
sucker punching i'm known for doing
dining dashes
yeah
and but mozzarella is cut from a cloth
where he's the street soldier and street
jesus what the [ __ ] you want to call him
i forget his real moniker yeah but we
love him because he would fight anybody
at any time yeah and he's a tough dude
don't like him
yeah we don't like you sucker punch you
know what sucker punching is the thing
the high school kids were doing on tick
tock and hurting people no and it was a
problem sucker punching is something the
worst thing is what people are doing to
asians throwing cover generations
exactly such a [ __ ]
if you want to address him on the
streets at dinner you go to the dinner
table hey when you finish this [ __ ]
steak i'll be outside waiting that's
fine and it's just me i even have my
problem with that no math i even have i
don't have a problem with that i don't
have a problem grown men i don't have a
pro i don't have a problem with that if
you're gonna fight right
but if i'm cold i'll tweet at dana hey
dana
you want me to drop the charger so you
don't go away in due time book me july
whatever on your next pay-per-view
against mazda so i can royally beat the
chevrolet and get paid for doesn't that
reward monsters at all for that [ __ ] and
awesome no i mean it gives him
a terrible match-up for him no but it's
also
the ufc no one's better at building
fights ufc can use all this footage and
clips and all that i think i'd do this
i'd say i'll tell you what i'll drop the
charges you got to fight me pay-per-view
but you don't get paid your money goes
to charity my money goes to me that's
what i do that's a good idea
because it's like you had 25 minutes to
fight yeah that's 35 minutes here's my
thing if they if they never fought and
you do this suck i will never condone a
sucker much ever but if you fought him
on the street whatever do your thing
either there's animosity talk to you
about your kids i get it yeah as a dad i
get it
but
three weeks prior you had 25 minutes
legally
what did colby say about his kids
he said he's a deputy he said he said he
was a deadbeat dad well that's not about
his kids that's about him
yeah he i don't think he said anything
out of your mouth but also ben asked me
to talk to you about your kids too it's
[ __ ] but also you got to remember
colby his entire
marketing model to sell tickets is to
get under your skin of course it's a
complete act dude you got it but you're
also like you're at the top of your game
my other thing is let's say let's say we
end up hating each other
i think colby and jorge were like you
and me best friends yeah i know each
other in and out yep
if you did something to me can you
imagine me suing you or i'm not even
suing me pressing charging and you're
going to prison
i don't give a [ __ ] how bad it is it's
so bad i would be like dude like someone
should like colby what are you doing
dude he's gonna go to prison you go on
with this he's going to prison did he
say right there chin yeah
yeah he didn't say anything about his
kids directly just called him a deadbeat
dad
who was alimony in child support the bad
father lies to his children you know the
state can press charges too in those
situations so you don't have to press
charges apparently the state i believe i
i'm not a lawyer so i should be careful
with this but i think so i think you can
get in trouble for that i think if
someone else is in danger you can but if
it's that i think the charges have to
come from kobe because if kobe went i'm
good no charges this is all over
yeah i if i'm colby i
because he and he can't get a fight he's
in this weird predicament camaro's
fighting you know in july against leon
edwards he's been looking for big fights
just go hey man i'm gonna stay busy i'll
drop the chargers give me [ __ ]
mozzarella again let me make it very
clear how much better i am then because
he's so much he's such a better fighter
yeah he is
i don't know man
without
guest domestic violence or assault
she can still do this the prosecutor can
okay but that's in domestic violence or
violence or assault violence yeah yeah
yeah that yeah that's that's obviously
you know you can get in some serious
trouble
it says the short answer is yes the
police can make arrests
refer the matter to the state of charges
the alleged victims wishes miami is not
[ __ ] around right now that d.a is
like you guys are shooting up you guys
are shooting at the beach so there's a
curfew you know in south beach you guys
are [ __ ] so they don't they don't
like this [ __ ]
miami doesn't [ __ ] around
and i i just think that it's
it's so ridiculous yeah it's it's
self-sabotage behavior is killing it he
has his tequila out he has his slightly
that's when you're working
as denzel washington said the devil
comes at your highest moment
and he's you got to like yourself and if
you don't think you deserve that he's
been through you know he's had damage
right his dad's doing life in prison for
murder i think positive yeah but also
remember coming from the stream
a lot of self-loathing there's a lot of
trauma there's a lot of [ __ ]
now
responsibility of being great and being
an example and you you defined yourself
for so long as being the street thug and
you lost the fight like yeah it's quite
embarrassing it's your way to get back
my only and i'm all about that my only
issue is you sucker punch a grown man
that is the biggest [ __ ] [ __ ] 100 of
this same thing with will smith you slap
a dude not at an award show where that
stuff can't defend himself
supposedly he's coming off a broken arm
he's in a sling they don't know if he
took the sling off just do the awards
you know what are you doing i guess
there is i guess the other side of the
coin is that words there's a point where
as a man if i'm mileing off to you and
i'm saying [ __ ] about your wife and i'm
me uh and you're
251 51 pounds yeah
uh there is a point where you're gonna
slap me but there's a point where
i'm behaving in a way where it's like
all right you know what i'm gonna i'm
gonna i'm gonna kick your [ __ ] ass
right now because you're a little [ __ ]
and you're talking about my wife like
this yeah what would you have done brian
if you if you were will smith right
there no i would have done it on the i
would have stood up like i if in
let's say the background's real
i was stunned went not funny dude
my my wife has alopecia where the [ __ ] i
told you to keep my wife's name at your
mouth multiple times i'ma see you in the
back [ __ ]
when you're done with this i will be
waiting for you
that's a fair call oh my girl my girl
goes but you know what that is
that's a man [ __ ] yeah those guys aren't
they're the biggest [ __ ] in the world
yeah yeah they're so soft
my my girl is with laughing because she
goes would you do that for me and i go
you know what babe
i'll tell you what no i wouldn't but
that night i would i would talk about
what how i should have done that
i would talk about all the things i
would have done the call out is way
better yeah they call out like they call
it like hey i told you i'm gonna see you
yep i'm gonna see you that's the way
that's that's the best way to do it no
no no no no no no no no no i'm not gonna
talk am i gonna do right here i'm gonna
i'm gonna wait for you i'm gonna wait
for you in the back dog i've known i
[ __ ] told you that's the way for you
in the
but i'm with b on this again i don't
think he handled the right way but
there's something like people talk all
this [ __ ] like haters right they were
remaining unanimous stuff like this and
unanimous they remain unanimous all the
stuff
yeah unanimous
but then when i find out who you are
and i come to your house keep the same
energy please
i have a skill set you do not have yes
i'm willing to go to the darkest places
that's right i'm willing to swim in the
waters you're not yeah mine's mine
hold on my entire career been in those
waters name the water papa name the
water well i said that about it i said
that about you because there was some
stuff going on and i said the problem
with certain people is that if they get
your attention
now now that they got your attention
your knees not coming off their [ __ ]
no
it's it's bad it's bad yeah yeah so so
you know there is something called
follow through
but i i uh
yeah so part of me with will it's like i
get it you get it yeah i get it but well
but also we have to remember that will's
been taking will's been sitting in his
seat taking it he's taking all of all
the [ __ ]
finally he's like you know what the
internet cop yeah i'm going to make i'm
going to five years yeah i you can't
push me it was it's been that was five
years if if my girl was let's say i was
uh married to jada smith and she goes
i'm gonna start red table tell you oh do
we not have enough money
wait for what but she she never has
enough attention bubba but i'll just go
oh she can't go and usually talk about
our personal life oh yeah what's wrong
with whatever it is she puts it all out
there you talk about missing tupac and
the letters he said what's wrong with
you whatever it takes enough
me too oh then in an interview i think
charlemagne had asked him about the
tupac situation so it's like now he's
going to ask and it was after she had
visited
so now he's getting these like interview
questions about two parts
yeah that's the problem she has no
respect but she bit that's how she takes
his power away
dude can you imagine
let's say your girl dated some f let's
say she dated heath ledger man who
passed away rest in peace and and that
was years ago way before you yeah and
every time his birthday comes up she's
posting about him posting letters
what are you doing i have a huge what
the [ __ ] are you doing i don't deal with
that what's the respect i go like this i
go where's the respect i go like this
you see ya that's what i do i would
always do that i if you don't like me or
you're going to do that like i've been
i've had that before with a woman who
like dissed me one time she started we
were dating for a little bit and she was
just inappropriately
hanging out with this district i was
like okay
so i went like this i go so this is all
good
you buy i just went i'll see you do it
every year yeah dude if i'm chris rock
you know their open relationship my joke
would if i'm chris rock i would have
been like all right well oh you want to
hit me on next dude all right i'm gonna
[ __ ] your i'ma [ __ ] jaden i'm gonna go
for jada now you know brilliant i'm
gonna [ __ ] jada i'ma [ __ ] the mom that's
what's happening now yeah and just
straight up yeah because we know you
guys get down like that
jim carrey went on what was talking
about it was really he had a great take
on it what'd he say
he said it was just you stole the people
that the devotion
that it takes to get to that to pull it
off it's their biggest night and you
stole everybody's fire when you walked
up there and slapped him like that yeah
like you didn't have the self-control
and it just came out of [ __ ] nowhere
and it wasn't that bad
he just he just went really hard he just
took the spot he's the only because i
love i love will smith but that was you
gotta you at least you gotta say what
you did was wrong there's not gray area
here that sucked that sucked you just
can't have it also kid i don't know how
many kids are watching also now that
nobody's watching but kids watching it
well now it's like now that's all they
want i know especially on tick tock and
all that there's one guy i was saying
you know so kids you're making violence
okay you really are and whether you
think that not everybody's going to do
that because what do we say what do you
say use your words don't use violence
and now kids are like well will smith
uses violence like the the
the
standard that you're setting is not good
use the words until i until i can't take
it anymore and i want to really hit
somebody it's like you know what i'm
saying is like there's no and hit a
smaller man yeah what i think's
happening is it's like the kid in school
his kid in school was getting bullied
bullied bullied will's getting bullied
bullied his wife's [ __ ] all these
other dudes he didn't bleed bloody blood
and then the kind of nerdy artistic kid
goes oh this is everyone's doing that
let me try it after months goes hey
[ __ ] dummy and then will goes what
and punches that kid and so the big
bullies who are really doing it yes and
to be honest it all stems from his wife
brian you run away from her dude right
you really think she's trying to take
her take his
100 percent too i think with that talk
like like
listen and that's fair that you say that
but i'm just like
but like i mean i don't know i don't
know if i just i don't know if i would
give her a humiliate your husband you
are humiliating your husband over and
over again you've ruined his brand and i
mean i've ruined his brand and and
everyone calls him a cup
she's not being respectful of that i
don't respect them she's not i got a
huge problem yeah i got a problem with
it huge problem with her she's not being
respectful at all and she's doing it why
because it monetize monetization
it gives her gives her power yeah and it
gets her view cause she can't handle the
fact that he's amazing she can't handle
the fact that he's at the top of this
game she can't handle the fact that he
won an oscar
you know what happened after he won the
oscar did she give him a big hug and a
kiss no they held hands like this
watched the rest of it and they went to
after parties and danced to get jiggy
with it in [ __ ] miami whatever this
song is all right there you go i [ __ ]
with that song i [ __ ] with all songs
all right what else
you guys don't know
come on so if will smith is already
laughing will smith himself found that
joke to be fun to him at that moment
right he was laughing
so then to look back and see that his
girlfriend who i'm sure we all have with
our friends
yeah we do yeah it's clear footage of
that here's my thing i think will was
like yeah that's funny and then he
looked and he was like oh i better do
something
[ __ ] little wayne
i i looked for it i could i didn't see
where that was where he looks back at
his wife it's everywhere dude but it's
everywhere brian you know i i did not
see that it's different
but did you see him look at her yes and
he's laughing looks over and she rolls
around okay look at him right there look
at him oh [ __ ] and look at her
uh she's not happy with it jada i love
you g.i jane two can't wait to see it
all right
see he's laughing and look at her
yeah so honestly it's lame yeah you have
disagreements with your girlfriend too
right i mean with your girl i have
disagreements sometimes i think certain
things are funny she doesn't i'm not
going to look at her and she'll be like
wait you didn't think it's funny i'm
going to go [ __ ] this guy up now well
i'm not him i think he was like oh if i
don't do this she's going to [ __ ] little
uzi which is still lame you know because
that joke itself is like the most little
[ __ ] thing it's so weak it's so weird
like a great quick throw yeah
she has a bald head okay almost in a
sense of combination
i don't think he knew that she had that
alopecia also also
cgi chain too are you talking about
where demi moore's a badass and hot as
[ __ ] that's what i'm talking about
that's what i'm talking about she was
hot as [ __ ]
that movie's great
yeah gi jan2 would be lit as [ __ ] would
jada what come on i mean i don't want to
see her in it but yeah i thought i do
i'm out dude i think jaden
let me see what he said violence is in
all of its forms his poisons destructed
my hair last night academy awards would
not accept inexcusable jokes at my
expense are part of the job but a joke
about jada's medical condition was too
much for me to bear and i react
emotionally i'd like to publicly
apologize to you chris i was out of line
i was wrong i'm bearing some actions
we're not indicative of the man i want
to be there's no place for violence in
this world of love and kindness
i also like to apologize to the academy
the producers of the show all the
attendees everyone watching around the
world i would like to apologize to the
williams family and my king and my king
richard family i deeply regret that my
behavior has
stained what was been in an otherwise
gorgeous journey for all of us i'm a
work in progress
i love the guy
i love the guy and i accept his apology
i love will smith yeah i don't care i
don't care enough
again
and he just [ __ ] made a mistake
everybody's all right everybody's
talking let's leave him alone i agree
it's so interesting how does like the
device twitter is like some people are
devices pro
will some people are pro chris yeah
[ __ ] people talk [ __ ] about his wife
what
yeah all right what do you got gin
elon musk put up a poll on twitter to
see uh
if
people on twitter who were following him
thought that twitter was a good place
where free speech was allowed a lot of
people said no and then he put up
another poll
asking two million votes yeah holy [ __ ]
that poll got two million votes isn't
that crazy the reach that he has do you
believe twitter really adheres to this
principle no
wow free speech oh and i guess he's
thinking about creating his own social
media platform where free speech is
allowed it's kind of like whatever goes
i get it you know social media back in
the day used to be
memes and fun and stuff like this that
turn in this weird talk right the
internet you see people just be fun now
it's just like a weapon for division
yeah but now it's become this weird
toxic political hater fed thing which
you're like i don't i don't want to
subscribe to this right it's hard to
have fun on this what's up like it's
filled with losers
it's like wow you're giving all these
losers a voice
but i need to sell tickets
start seven 77 philly
why does he have an opinion oh i'm out
dude i don't subscribe to this i don't
i'm never on twitter ever ever ever
i don't have a twitter the internet used
to be so lit dude you should be so much
fun and positive and
now it's just like
who who can we take down now i went on
twitter once and i was like oh my god
twitter's probably the most talk yeah i
had it for i had it for a month and then
i was like oh this is horrible yeah
deleted it
if elon open up something that'd be
pretty cool yeah i'd support it yeah
still would i
there is a
oh there is a video of a
kid in a truck while a tornado is
happening in texas and it shows the
truck spinning it flips over and flips
back onto its wheels and he just drives
off
the kid like a cat
with a few scratches but other than that
he is unscathed he knew that there was
going to be some sort of storm happening
the day prior but he really didn't want
to miss this job interview he had hey we
do not know if he got the job or not
i hope he got that [ __ ] job whoa
where's it at 16 year old
somehow survives this encounter with a
tornado in eglin texas monday storm
chaser video captures boom back up being
flipped hit the gas [ __ ] around
then flip right side again allowing the
team to then drive away
riley leone says he knew there was going
to be stormy weather on monday but he
had a job interview he didn't want to
miss
a video
with briar rather before he even got
back home dude i have actually gotten
home from from the wreck
and my brother's like have you have you
seen the video not like what video thank
you
like that's actually me
and he was like are you for real like
yeah
i thought of god for giving me another
chance in this life
because
he probably did so a
because you see it was his dad's and he
worked hard to be able to buy it from
him however that kid's in that [ __ ] yeah
also why is he driving in the tournament
because he was trying to get a good job
in that company
hopefully that's a chevy
hey whoever that job is give him the
goddamn
this guy went through the eye of a
tornado yeah we had to get the job yeah
so why should we hire him
it was a [ __ ] twister why do you
think you do this job uh well i've seen
the movie twister i literally did that
to make it here yeah and he still didn't
make the [ __ ] interview
yeah you were late dude sorry
i don't know man
my brother was like did you see the
video oh wait but you know it was at
home i'm late because what happened was
a tornado
flew in my car
and they're never going to believe that
they're like drunk
and then you can see this like oh [ __ ]
we should probably give that kid a job
you gotta give him a job
i wonder what the job was i don't know
he didn't it didn't say like rbc
this is just some not a job you want
yeah give me give that kid the goddamn
job man give him that [ __ ] job
we talked about phil collins a few weeks
ago and this is a video of his last
performance yeah i guess it was too weak
now to continue spinal cord injury man
this video here yeah
at the o2
of course we're playing in london and
it's the last stop of our tour
and it's the last show
for genesis
what a career though yeah oh that's
emotional bro
who's the cameraman
that's terrible
stay on the real version dude
[Applause]
yeah you gotta go get real jobs
it sucks when you got a [ __ ] spinal
cord injury it's a number of things they
say oh yeah not just spinal cord oh
really yeah body breaks down yeah damn
and he's what like he's like 70
something 71.
first time touring in 14 years oh damn
he's like let me get one last one in
dude
i think about my father and he's 81 and
how how robust he is he's crushing it
it's unbelievable he's not like great
shape your dad's tall right how about
six more huge six four 260. he's heavier
than that yeah he's got a belly on him
but the [ __ ] yeah
i think your dad wasn't as much of that
well you're big you're even bigger
you're going to be hey hey
god dad got a gut he's got it he's got a
gut he eats bonanza on top of his gut
like this yeah yeah he just has got to
but he's i'm shocked you didn't get his
height
while my mom's five too
oh [ __ ] my mom's tiny little italian
lady
he's just giant german german [ __ ]
wait how tall is your sister
she's four yeah my sister's uh
no my sister's uh five six normal oh no
okay okay you're dead 300. uh what were
you saying
your dad 300 though yeah no he does not
do that he's not 250. he's two i
probably tell your dad to come see me in
utah you're muscle hey hey you know you
got not a chance you didn't have to do
40. no he's not he did a bit like trump
yeah brian you guys same body as trump
giant yeah 300. my dad came to see you
tell your dad to come see me
when i'm in utah when are you going to
be in utah april 8 and april 9th
i will
that's a [ __ ] lie it's tough to get
papa calling out of the house he he
won't no i know i get a [ __ ] he's
ridiculous my buddy wanted to hook up
with brendan over the weekend would you
say
my buddy wanted to hook up with you but
he doesn't look up link link up was like
i was like
i was like
we got to a certain age where i was like
that's brennan is unless you have a
private plane or you can you have an
idea that's going to make him 50 million
dollars
he doesn't have time he's no no the time
he has he's going to go see his kids
he's not going to hang out
never
never it's not a personal thing she said
i had somebody who's going to hook up
with brendan what i get people ask me to
put me in touch with rogan can you put
me in touch with rogan i have an idea or
even better put me in touch with rogan
i've got some amazing stories i think
he'd love to hear on the podcast yes and
i say
i will absolutely
call him right now
what else you got
the drummer for foo fighters
he died as we all know right now but uh
they said they had like 10 different
here's my thing it says they had 10
substances for his death you know how
long it takes to get an autopsy
that's what that's what doesn't mean
yeah weeks weeks well maybe they did it
that night in brazil
that knew him that they saw him take
substances i don't know no there's no
way i doubt that
they're saying it came from the autopsy
i think how long it takes
yeah it takes forever it takes a long
time takes weeks but it's been now if
they hurry up all they have to do is
when do they hurry up especially [ __ ]
brazil or columbia a celebrity like that
no no no not one [ __ ] uh
bob saget also back to oscars you didn't
give bob saget a tribute oh they did it
you didn't mention bob saget that
amazing are you out of your [ __ ] mind
weird
you don't mention the great bob's asner
you guys are too young but ed asmr for
the mary tyler won't show ed asner one
of these oh yeah they didn't mention him
no no one of them bob saget just passed
away how do you oversee that
i don't know but i i didn't even realize
that four to six weeks this came out a
day after yeah i don't i don't think
that's in brazil columbia right colombia
how okay
i don't know now i believe he had that
you know the stuff they listed you know
and he also owed unto him for from
heroin why does it take you struggle
with drugs why does it take a taxology
report it takes so long to get a can you
look at that why does it i mean they
want to get those tests right i would
i'd assume it took forever to get my
brothers back no no were you looking at
brian why does it take so long to get a
toxic
the answer left charlie in the backlog
of the lab which process all yeah
so they they they push to the front of
the line yeah probably over there you
know i i got the news about this right
before i went on stage oh it was like
the word i was like what i was like you
wanna i was like you wanted to tell me
this one before i go on stage it wasn't
a friend just some random person he was
a fan he was taking pictures at the show
he goes man he goes i think you're a
great guitar player he goes uh he goes i
follow you on instagram and stuff he
goes we like a lot of the same music and
then he goes uh yeah man did you hear
about taylor hawkins oh he did and i was
like and i was like oh i was like no he
goes oh man he died and i was like
that's what you wanted to say to me
before i was there though he didn't know
you know but like people at the show
were literally like
hey
the drummer from the foo fighters died
don't tell chappelle yeah
that's the band i've seen the most oh
[ __ ] that's a bummer that's the band
i've seen the most that must have hit
you hard though oh bruh i was [ __ ]
devastated it was so hard to like
terrible he had a hair i even i even
have a foo fighters joke but like it it
was tough i don't know it was really
tough
i just couldn't apparently they said his
heart is twice the weight of a normal
heart okay they say that's what happens
cocaine adds weight to your heart yeah
that's chris penn with sean penn's
brother that's the same thing enlarge
your heart what about some of those
athletes that have died of like enlarged
they just pass out i think those are
very tall people but i think in this
case you you you actually will
grow your heart when you do that oh
process causing heart enlargement that
can ultimately lead to sudden death yeah
causes the abnormal buildup of primitive
proteins in a heart muscle yep
not good yeah that's not good that poor
guy man they said he was a wife and kids
three kids he was complaining about
chest pains yeah three kids he right he
he rode bikes just like you yeah and you
say the same way he right right right up
right out in calabasas yeah that's not
terrible cocaine terrible
yeah broke my [ __ ] heart
all right what is that about antonio
brown i'll show you after this one so
you guys were talking about um
hold on a second bob saget so i guess
there is new audio that came out they
don't we don't actually have the audio
samples but someone that worked at that
place said that
uh bob sage was complaining of long-term
covet symphony brendan you kind of
predict this yeah but you know what i i
know bob and bob was also the biggest
hypochondriac on the planet he was also
like bob you could have found bob at any
time in his life and he'd be like i
don't know i just don't feel you know so
i mean
i take this with a grain of salt there's
something going on i don't i don't think
it's covered 19 there's something going
on here and and here's the thing so even
with the trail stone and stuff which he
did at a four seasons i think bob was
standing in four seasons wouldn't they
have
video right of anybody come in the room
because also but they're not saying
anything and the family's defend it like
crazy i there's just something more to
this story i think he just fell hit his
head really i don't buy that and then i
don't buy that i don't buy that with the
impact that they said
you literally have experts go it's
impossible
who fell straight back i think i'm just
saying the experts brian i'd i'm with
you i'm saying the experts who
specialize in that go it'd literally be
impossible to smack your head and [ __ ]
fracture the front and the back
because only we could fall out of a 30
feet building or get hit with a bat it
was the only time one guy i don't know i
i don't know i mean and these are
pictures from his actual hotel what if
he got hit in that they fell on a marble
floor or in the bathroom again these
experts are saying that's not true
there's something to this man
and now whether the family's defending
like this crazy i don't know man that's
a little weird there's something to it
we're not getting all the facts
no
okay so this girl who used to date
deshawn
jackson
deshawn watson or jack jackson
uh
so antonio brown slept with her
obviously in this story post that he did
and then he told her return my five
thousand dollars i'm gonna expose you
she took five thousand dollars that's
what he's saying he's claiming that and
then he has dms so he goes over here
i had to look up what bc meant but
that's uh what does that mean
um [ __ ] i forgot already
a [ __ ] no no no no no no no no no no no
yes there you go
got that
get it
sit it says sydney christine got the
blank on b [ __ ] on
on birth control may i see what she
looks like we'll do it after but
aggressive here is the
dna please don't do that to me i'm
really sorry i just didn't like the way
you were talking to me this thing can
help anything what can we do to fix it i
don't like the way he talks to her
though
send my money [ __ ] 5k or you'll be
exposed i will what's that paypal oh you
know stop playing with me [ __ ] i'm
going to show you this time okay i'm
trying to send it back to you damn so i
guess so she really stole the money
it seems like she's admitting that she
took his money yeah oh [ __ ] yeah so he
exposed her she's super 5k this is her
wow good deal
this is her this is her i went to her
instagram as well 5k
she claims to be a producer as well with
a billboard number one i don't know much
about this and she's vegan she stole
five grand from them yeah who steals
money hey apparently her huh go that one
gym for me yeah that's not cool
take my five grand
[Laughter]
with your raw take my five grand
but she's brian help you out she stole
it take 10.
you can't reward her behavior just don't
just leave my wife i don't know do you
think she looks good naked do you think
she's good in bed she's so pretty all
right
damn she's so pretty she's a thief which
is troublesome it's kind of hot yeah
she's kind of hot your character is bad
but you're bothering me oh bad all right
get me out of here
she's yeah she's uh she'll steal your
money
all right 5k
take my father he's joking but i
guarantee it i gotta be the same man i'd
be like yeah you know i left it out
you know what i mean i'd be like ah did
she yeah yeah i'll take it i'm like hey
i assume you just took that five kicks
that's your usual fee but um when do i
see you again yeah
well i wouldn't even i probably i'd be
for me it'd probably be awkward i would
say nothing so much money yeah i'd be
awkward
whatever uh when do i see you again oh
what are you at
uh so on monday biden was asking or
answering questions about ukraine and
then uh people saw that he was using a
cheat sheet basically dude he's an 80
something that's what you were saying
he's like he's he's losing his cognitive
whatever you do you see when he went off
the cuff
so they uh they have to write everything
from him went off the cuff and started
talking [ __ ] about putin yeah saying
he's like a murderer and all this stuff
and then putin what they don't realize
this actually adds to what the narrative
that russia is playing on their news
programs they're saying that the west is
you know purposely doing this yes trying
to make seem like we're you know
horrible people because they want to you
know invade us stuff like this so it
adds to putin yes and this just adds to
the nuclear war problem yeah
um
i've always said it they asked him off
the cuff and he was just like my thing
about joe biden is what i would say from
day one before he was president
everything else he's not a smart guy and
there's nothing i think he was i think
he was a smart guy he's never smart i
think he's pretty smart i mean he's not
like elon musk smart he's just never he
was never considered smart the knock on
him is he's a blowhard but you know not
that he's a bad guy he's just not um
i got like
five minutes five minutes yeah uh let me
just do this one
this is stephen wonderboy thompson with
for st pierre and boss rooten
hey guys did y'all see the uh the oscars
last night yep
well i thought if they would give out an
award for the worst haircut
it would definitely
[Applause]
[Laughter]
people have made fun of gsp's haircut
they say he looks better with the shave
tape he looks so much better
let me see that again it looks so much
better
gsp said you deserve an oscar for how
well you sold it
well i thought if they would give out an
award for the worst haircut
it would definitely go to ugsb
[Applause]
that's funny all right all right
those are great man where are you at uh
next
wednesday shop and friends be our eighth
sold out show we got the monsters on it
shop and friends one show only 8 p.m
hollywood improv the best shows man we
have so much fun yeah ellie's coming
back dude nobody's coming back one show
at a time and then uh the big boy
phoenix arizona stand up live is april
14th through the 16th austin texas moon
tower comedy festival cap city april
22nd 23rd april 21st i'll be doing spots
all around the uh comedy festival uh
that's it man april 22nd big night for
your boy the special drops on think boy
only i have a bunch of more information
for you and then thick mudder is april
9th at 10 30 a.m go to toughmudder.com
you'll see the thick mudder there's a
picture of me if you use the promo code
sickboy you get 10 off your signup fee
sure get some tampa florida i'll see you
in two weeks april 15 to the 16. i got
port charlotte florida the sonic comedy
theater april 21-23
las vegas nevada's wise guys the end of
the week the month april 28 to 30.
and uh may 19th brea improv
two shows i am taping my special
get your tickets i'll put those up today
awesome all right salt lake city uh
april 8th and april 9th two nights only
uh wise guys comedy club and then may
6th to 7th san diego california uh new
comedy club called my drop comedy club
and then i'm doing a one-nighter in uh
phoenix
in the hometown at stand up live
boom
all righty all right that's it kids love
ya thanks for tuning in thank you